all right ready ready from Ridgid where
you bro
Michigan Detroit areas right suburb yeah
both is a great trailing a great
childhood traveling around in different
places a Colorado a Boston Louisiana and
then I ended up in Florida and what was
happening was I was I was drinking too
much and I was an alcoholic we're going
okay so but I found a a and and I got
sober but I didn't stay sober it lasted
for about a year and a half and then I
relapsed and I don't really laughing
ever since basically so I have good
periods then I had bad period yeah drugs
are part of my story yeah I think so
yeah sure I believe so
sometimes alcohol can be the worst hug
tear you up I mean look at him
and so what buddy Freeman you started
with drinking when I felt when I when I
knew I was an alcoholic was when I was
35 you know in Florida I got sober like
I said for a year and a half everything
was great but then I drank then I got
sober again and then I drank it's been
like that ever since I'm 64 now yeah 55
about 7 years I don't know exactly yeah
I have one of those SROs yeah it still
counts as homeless on day when they do
the census but I've had one for about 3
years that I was on the streets for
three years - I missed your meth and
crack try to stay away from the crack
it's too expensive I don't any like frat
so I gotta wait so by doing that I don't
do crack yeah it's a lot cheaper
substances way out yeah and it's a way
crack with a way out of drinking and no
method the way out of crack I have it I
have that addictive personality I'm
filming alcoholic
you believe that the the the drive to
know some painful event in your past not
that El Cajon says tricky thing you know
is it's not I'm not trying to numb some
pain I don't think maybe I I have it was
wonderful I just I just have that
addictive personality that dependence on
and something I think I think it's that
I can I think I think it's uh not
everybody has it
some people do there's a small
percentage of people who do and you
either got it or you don't
it's it's it's a second disease mental
physical and spiritual I think that's
what my problem is I know that's what it
is I've never been able to stay sober
though for longer than the first time I
got sober was like a year and a half as
long as I was and after a year and a
half everything was beautiful birds were
chirping I was happy the Sun was shining
and I felt great all the time and I
drank it I was drinking like 18 beers a
day about 24 beers everyday and going to
work
I tore myself up and and then I lost my
job not related to drinking and I met a
girl real pretty girl I fell in love
with it and she smoked crack and I
smoked then I started in separately it
was it
and then I smoke crack for a while then
then it was meth because I want to eat I
don't even like crack anymore just
overdoing it and that's that and where
do you see what do you see for your
future it's that really a problem
I'm 64 so I'm retired I don't get much
money a month but I get it and I you
know next year I'll be able to get
Medicaid or Medicare or whatever it is
Medicaid yeah in a section 8 housing and
that's it I don't I don't have a future
that's my future really I enjoy life
lowest I had many low points nay
I think I was in Alabama one set of
those girls pretty low I was hitchhiking
around the country you know I was pretty
yeah I was at my 20 still and I was up I
was writing freight trains in the hopper
training you know and I was just doing
it for fun I wasn't doing it to get
anywhere it's something to do but then
if a game then it got it I got messed up
and I couldn't get out so I was trapped
and it got pretty bad yeah sure sure
thank you